I can wear your ass give you this I'm so
crazy because I've actually been wanting
to call you guys long as that for a long
time oh my gosh I'm getting emotional
good morning today is another beautiful
day employee and we are heading out now
we're going to be going to Versailles
we're already kind of running late as we
have been every single morning because
we are just exhausted we've been going
asleep really really late every night
and trying to wake up really early but
we still can't manage to get out I'm
really under wedding I know all that
wedding planning was really exhausting
those first few days but it's okay we're
going to be coming back so whatever we
don't get to seeing this trip we'll see
you next trip relief that's going to be
the wedding trip so maybe we're going to
blame the wedding we're going to be too
busy with the wedding it's okay we'll
come back person will always be here but
we got ahead of them vamanos oh boy I
think he's better didn't lock you inside
one interesting thing about France is
that they don't pick up dog food baths
themselves like this just everywhere
I'll proof is everywhere you step into a
dry wind is messy do it instead with
some I did but okay so grown-up
my family and I used to travel a lot and
mommy we still do I'm traveling with my
family right now I remember though
clearly that my dad and my mom work
would be on opposing ends at one debate
my mom's always willing to hike and walk
but my dad is less prone for that but
and he's aging it seems like he's more
willing to walk around how come you're
uh you're willing to walk around now it
is because I have nothing to carry it
and I don't have to carry you I don't
have a carrot of video recorded the
video camera the one I had was like to
try to see you have clearly shoulder so
I just didn't want to carry camcorder
and 80 old kids but now I don't have any
of this right and that's what I'm doing
now portraits portraits of path and this
guy got the camera holding like a
cameras a lot lighter than when I had a
Shiro carries a gigantic for bury his
about this big just a better look as big
as my counterpart along with the battery
lasts like that flowers oh there's a
lesson to say yeah I got this camera
specifically to analyze the whole thing
get to take a look was it be my memory
cards are like physics and they last the
whole day I don't need to talk about
these only 60 minutes be really
selective is looking at for yeah they
take things for granted cause it's a lot
easier now that each new generation
technology and only you could be smaller
NASA Kari is smaller more efficient I
think okay let's work on that okay last
time five years ago we came to Paris and
then we went to Paris and Woodside and
Katie got big pumpkins and got $200 in
his wallet and all his IDs and stuff
like that but the good thing about being
sick pocketed is that you will never get
pickpocketed again at least not as
easily because since that day I used to
put my wallet in my back pocket ever
since I got pickpocketed so I've never
put my wallet in my back pocket ever
again I always put my front pocket
because I know for a fact that's a lot
harder to reach but I still don't put in
my front pocket when I travel I actually
wear a fanny pack and I wear button-up
shirts long enough to cover up the fanny
pack and always later on a lot of
jackets and a lot of stuff to
overcompensate so that a pickpocket
people have to like work around all your
layers of clothing and stuff like that
and open a zipper and all that kind of
stuff make it really hard for them it's
probably still not fail-proof but it's a
really good precautionary step so yeah I
mean I got pickpocketed in Versailles
last time very eye-opening experience
that palace make a girl look
[Music]
-
it's my idea so when I go home one
minute baby yeah you got to get rid of
all the furniture brought it all the way
out of it all the way out of it just go
see it I'm hungry out of my life
[Music]
district and everything like and penis
while he's walking the walk
and that's crazy that's where I'm trying
to look like that with a Walter the goal
is law
my crib how do you feel the others of
your crib yes we're volunteers people
inside let's measure out a baby I see a
lot party it pay me like Lily they pay
you for them to hang out here yeah and
I've never seen that money
you're hiding after tired I like sister
now people generally start off like
really strong with focused stuff for the
first twenty thirty minutes then
eventually it's like so rude you're like
I'm done I think we lasted roughly 30
minutes now I see lots of like two
minutes
very much so I think it feel like these
people are really tall from their
statues and like the grand jurors and
buildings like a beast aghori longest
people yeah they're a quarter than a
smaller than modern-day people here
probably yeah well I don't know you and
I are very bored
I think this isn't like most impressive
room we've walked in here but those
churches they're pretty intense here's
gonna be busy
they're pretty precious Oleanna
interpret in town I know how do they do
it I don't know Marvel oh my gosh I will
love it in here because as a kid I
didn't drink enough water because I
hated drinking water and I thought be
thirsty but my body would be hot a lot I
needed to cool down now let's play on
the floor on the tile to cool down but
marble though and that's this is another
ball game in terms of being cold yeah I
would have loved this of the kids look
at that fireplace if enough latrine
maybe you can't he did that the same
thing is if I play a real fire and look
at that piece of wood you look what you
receive you can make a really good fun
but like a statue of like a bus like a
bus that's that the bust
you were like bus they resisting me
until they have another like man you're
plus if you have very good spatial
features annoyed at you
they have really prominent eyes nose
like she phoned everything I think we
would have that too I could see in a
screaming fun
feelings are amazing I wonder how much
time people from back then actually
spent wouldn't thought that stealing the
whole thing here is doing some of these
people and you'll probably just be
looking to do a short you tomato pilot
or a prize look up every day you spend
the whole you're holding school yeah
[Music]
right yeah many candle all can get to
light the candle because a two hours job
but I'm going to like them that's one
the first one is where so like all this
stuff started looking to kind of the
same to us after a while and like I wish
you should start breathing through it
because you know I want to see something
different but it keeps getting better
and better if we're not breathing
through a bright room that we go into
they just like laugh and loud and blow
Isaac is a natural war photographer I
believe because he's been taking a lot
of pictures with the camera that we
bought him for Christmas and you've been
taking pictures of us it's the Eiffel
Tower photo that KP posted of us kissing
I was thinking about Isaac looks a
little bit weird but yeah hehe I would
pick that photo you really good yes he
has an aegyo i we need a nurture that in
him we gotta buy now cameras and I think
he's really interested in it too and you
have to teach him yes he saw a whale
actual feels like the knowledge for me
I've always felt like I've been very
lucky and like to find a passion and
find something that I was naturally good
at you know I guess now have
I still have never found it you've got
explore like a childhood at a time for
exploration you know where between us -
it's like we're trying to create that
kind of environment for Isaac where you
can explore you probably won't remember
a lot of these trips you know I you know
it's like a waste of money all that
stuff fine yeah you won't remember it
but you know there's something about it
that you can take away that is
intangible you can explain what it is
but he's going to take away something
good that that's how I grew up you know
you explore your 40 floor something kids
can come out of it you know ask your
like right now the tire can just might
be his thing I couldn't have taken a
photo that good like how you could hit L
over here asking him like what you have
you know serious kill time it's kind of
great to get down for down-and-dirty I
think that best roof is hardened him lay
it in
look at it yeah I'm going to try to play
my guard in this whole reaction so I can
go to the guard existing never end house
it's too big this is all I will point
[Music]
under power feeding
[Music]
I'm looking for that the clerk's because
Garvin as American and you see all these
movies and stuff they're always being
éclairs and I just really wanted to get
into clear Jeremy first of course they
messy oh you're going to walk out there
ain't no real bill cost me extra soft
and weight field in your mouth holding
in there I don't know what I really
think I'm a domestic liar I take it out
big mouth about making a mask a to
making a dinner i hot chocolate a minute
there's was cream and then it's sort of
looking like creams with a little bit of
chocolate now it's too dark you know
what might be deceiving but Sir Tom gold
will know
iver to do uh hotness melting what a
fail this is a fossil envision save it
we finally made it outdoors this whole
time we kept going through inside of a
palace which is cool and I was quite an
experience but yeah like after saying so
much you got repetitive we're like okay
where's the eggs I want to do the garden
[Music]
[Music]
really like these pictures Michael Sata
was so I was trying to frame them up to
take a nice picture of the Falcon and
then your mom was like oh no look at the
background a lot of instructions it
doesn't really look good so I feel like
I was applying postcard I mean your dad
was like exactly that's what I'm saying
if you really like to see this buy a
postcard such a public campaign say
figure yet throughs at the same time
unless you want to be the picture that
you take it yourself yes most people
experience god I'm sorry
look at my down you're gonna live
hanging these photos like that was so
2017 when a dad was so popular
[Music]
[Laughter]
you should I wish I look like that oh my
god - am i funny we're gonna go in a
threesome our Bionic christinatours I'm
excited but I don't have an appetite yet
as we just finished eating so hopefully
by the time we go on this road or hungry
again today highly doubt
[Music]
boots or heads again we found the guy
we're looking at this famous long rims
in every language the phrase I love you
it's really such a long video I thought
it well you know I am what do you see a
long day
oh my man alright so we're at our first
stop on this tour is our first food soft
our guide was letting us know that this
particular bakery won the best would get
and doesn't 11 this specific district
the 18th district they have no Ward and
when you win it you get that award for
four years and then if you win it they
are appointed to baseball the recipe
there you go very big that's a really
exactly yes bakeries that have the word
like cool on share that means that
they're actually baking bread on that
site so they're not buying it from other
places other bakeries that they try to
put that word Boulanger on their bakery
and they don't bake on that premises
they get fined and they take their
baking seriously I hear ya I think they
see their food seriously here that's
true that's why I love Paris hello sis
bread infringement with Marius roaches
and perfect our little daughter there's
a like a PITA sometimes a simple Java
different because instead of is much
much better than Peter Barron Evita
[Music]
some cakes I'll I said I did we shoot
like this not that
Oh Oh texture is a lot softer than a
look that's good that's paint like a
feeds a little bit not the tomato sauce
all right ready Spanish bakery I am
hunter G shop from home the du fromage
omelette du fromage X is laboratory
[Music]
what's this place called
la bete from a key that's why I see a
lot remember you you're like geez I
think I choose a goat cheese oh man it
smells like cheese in here kind of takes
some getting used to but I can see how
we can smell really good to the stomach
yeah Kelpie oh yeah like it finish your
piece already oh oh wow oh i holding in
the mouth you like to choose better than
the bread then I can tell Pat
[Music]
okay so our guy just let us know about
this butcher shop you take a lot of
pride in their meat just be up there all
of that is their metal and there is
displaying their medals in use and you
want to look for metals when you go to a
butcher shop that's how you know you can
get the best quality vegetarian one day
when you realize is everything about
food I got it so this is pork with
[ __ ] sake it I live in Cuba good job
I'm talking to slash Wow
oh this piece here so good it's like ham
meat if your Filipino or your Cantonese
you know what electron is it's like the
roasted pig and then when they cut it
you got the skin and the fat and the
meat we've got the layering of
everything that was like ham meets that
amazing oh wow you like that romantic oh
you know chocolate fan I'm more the same
when I big dark
I got much Andy you're supersonic
chocolate they have let's try it
Cheers sorry chocolate don't taste the
sobbing but it's really good I really
owe my case without me now oh it's real
subtle real real trouble mmm but
officers coming out of my mind you know
asabi is a small hobby play reppin fairy
and oh I never know what something
trouble to work together they did all
right fire lacquer was Labor's you get I
got a favorite friend rainbow did you
like your chocolate yeah it's delicious
which ones that one
yeah let's try it I forgot to say just
pointing either cuz it looks cool
Cheers
[Music]
no idea what it is complicated there's
good macaroons honestly I really don't
care what flavor is one they're just
really sweet it's like so sweet to the
point where the flavor doesn't really
stand out as much at the texture day and
the texture is really what I'm eating
for this guy crushed and soft and chewy
at the same time texts that don't really
mix together huh oh thank you very good
[Music]
very helpful thoughts exactly
but this is the thing disabilities like
expect the one in the states are so hard
it's just not good it is not as sweet
and safer than the statewide iPhone back
home all hands like half of a macaron
I'm like oh god it's way too sweet I
can't do it but these aren't perfect
this one petal of it in America they
make everything worse huh you're so
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
this is where we're going to be hitting
the baguette I'm trying to make it you
know thank you I would look watching
YouTube's inside super Cheers
[Music]
right now I just mean sound part of the
baguette and I name the middle
isolationist and logistic a salami yeah
there it is
garlic garlic these are some awesome
meat but this one in particular is
pretty distinct and it's pretty hardcore
in terms of the flavor definitely some
internal organ type of thing going on
with it
got to get used to that flavor okay I
ain't gonna try yo yo you like this
maybe that's delicious
already try to fill the second one high
five
okay
cheers everybody Sunday's okay okay
thank you
what it's what what it's baby Bell on
steroids
something huge
follow me Lana how did you not notice I
just go like I don't think ugly felt it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I know how it's going to be very sorry
it was one thing to get in it's another
thing to get out
[Music]